welcome to the show it is a new year and
I want to talk just a little bit about
my plan for 2020 not specifically about
election coverage we'll talk about that
later but but a little more generally
about what's going on in American
political society one of the goals that
I have for 2020 for the show is to do
everything I can to reverse the hyper
normalization of radical unhinged
behavior and actions and it's it's been
really tough I mean we've talked about
this before and sometimes people will
call in about it we've experienced all
of us a sort of desensitization and
normalization under Donald Trump where
every norm countless ethics rules the
way we talk about politics the way we do
diplomacy the way we interact with other
world leaders and countries it's all
gone out the window and between the
scandal fatigue and being desensitized
we all to a degree start to see crazy
stuff as less crazy than we would have
in years past or even six months ago so
today I want to talk about just a real
issue and I want to do it carefully and
that issue is how do more people not
care that the President of the United
States is mentally unwell or we can use
the term mentally ill and I want to be
careful I don't want to stigmatize
mental illness because it doesn't
deserve to be stigmatized I don't want
to laugh at mental illness because it's
not a laughing matter nor do I want to
conflate things that shouldn't be
conflated so for example being ignorant
about politics and economics as our
president is is not mental illness it's
not mental instability two different
things being a cheater in relationships
and golf and business is not mental
illness being an immoral person is not
mental illness lacking empathy is not
mental illness but these things can be
connected to mental illness and the fact
that too many people seem uninterested
in recognizing that Donald Trump is
mentally unwell is a very bad sign
for society there's a recent piece in
salon that I encourage you to read by
Chauncey de vega where Chauncey says six
societies normalize the aberrant and
abhorrent behavior of their leaders and
other elites that behavior in turn
becomes a pathology of sorts which
infects the general public this has
infected trumpets many of them not all
met some of them have ulterior motives
we are hearing regularly from the mental
health community more and more about
this man who is in charge of the country
we've heard from psychiatry professor
dr. John Gartner on the program multiple
times who told us the various conditions
that Donald Trump may have these are not
jokes this is not making fun this is not
being hyperbolic this is a red-alert we
have a mentally ill president psychiatry
professor dr. bandy Lee from Yale said
recently that Nancy Pelosi could have
Donald Trump and voluntarily evaluated
because he may be a threat to public
safety now whether she actually can do
it or not and whether Trump would would
submit to that it's unlikely but this is
an argument that another mental health
professional is making and immediately
banned eally was excoriated by the Trump
astride how dare we inquire about the
mental health of the president we then
have psychiatrist
Justin Frank who says Trump is terrified
angry and extremely dangerous and that
conflict quote gives him life there have
been other leading mental health
professionals who have described Donald
Trump as psychotic now psychotic we've
got to be careful with the stuff
psychotic is often used colloquially in
society to mean a wacky or eccentric or
quirky person mental health
professionals are using the term
medically psychosis is a severe mental
disorder in which thought and emotions
are so impaired that contact is lost
with external reality that is in line
with much of what the people around
Donald Trump have been reporting is
going on
Chauncy to Vega goes on to write in his
salon piece that we are seeing now
something that relates to what
philosopher Henry
described as a dis imagination machine
this is a really important concept the
dis imagination machine is the apparatus
that includes images institutions
discourse media political movements
parties it prevents people from properly
bearing witness to phenomena and to
remembering those phenomena in a way
that applies critical thinking and a
critique it prevents people from being
critically informed even the ways in
which we are talking about Donald
Trump's behavior sort of is doing this
I'll give you an example when we say
Trump's behavior is unreal
there's an implied meaning which is we
mean that it's outrageous behavior we
mean that it's unacceptable behavior
that it has to be stopped
but when we use the word unreal it also
implies it's not real it's not really
happening the way that it appears to be
and Donald Trump has pushed this
remember Donald Trump said what you are
seeing and reading is not actually
happening it's not actually real so
Chauncey to Vegas conclusion is that
when we talk about is fascism coming is
totally totalitarianism coming whatever
we won't know it because it will become
the new normal very slowly just like
having a mentally ill president
increasingly has become the norm
many Republicans don't care because
they've get they've got their judges in
there getting their nominations
installed they're getting stuff done
while the focus is on Donald Trump they
just pretend that Donald Trump is okay
but for too many people they have
actually fallen into this normalization
2020 is going to be a real test for the
country I'm going to avoid I'm going to
try to do my part better said to avoid
the continued normalization of what is
mentally ill behavior without conflating
that with just an ignorant president
with an immoral president with an
unethical president these are different
issues we are not going to stigmatize
mental illness but at a certain point
when this number of mental health
professionals are sounding the alarm and
half the country seems not to care or
simply to refuse to see reality it is
starting to infect the country exactly
the way that Chauncey de vega writes in
salon we're going to link to that piece
in the disk
for the YouTube clip for this story and
I want to hear from you about this I
want to tell you about a really great
YouTube channel we're partnering with
it's called up flip TV and they've just
recently launched they've have some
excellent content for anybody interested
in business and entrepreneurship check
them out at david pakman.com slash flip
that's f li p
that'll redirect you to their youtube
channel make sure to subscribe while
you're there it is a YouTube channel
that I'd recommend to anyone in the
David Pakman show audience who owns a
business runs a business it's thinking
about starting a business or even if you
just like learning new things about how
business works they interview successful
entrepreneurs business owners giving
them a place to tell their stories and
share strategies so viewers can benefit
from their insight and apply their
wisdom to your own businesses all of the
content is about educating and inspiring
people in each video up flip TV
showcases a different type of startup it
could be a coffee shop or a landscaping
business or a real estate agency you'll
see how the business was often started
from scratch what a workday looks like
how to become and remain successful in
that business and they don't just
interview people they actually examine
each business from inside out in a
really unique way that distills the
valuable lessons that you can take from
their stories I find the content
fascinating they're friends of the David
Pakman show I would love it if you would
go and support their new YouTube channel
and what they're doing I think you'll
very quickly become a fan like I said
get there by going to david pakman.com
slash flip
that's FL IP and make sure to subscribe
to their channel when you're there